الدومينيكان
مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء ، نحن نركز بشكل كبير
على احتياجات أوكرانيا من الطاقة
، تواصل روسيا الروسية مهاجمة
البنية التحتية للطاقة في أوكرانيا ، لكننا
نرفض السماح للأوكرانيين بالتجميد أو
التجويع بسبب
الحرب الوحشية غير القانونية وغير الإنسانية التي شنتها روسيا ،
لذا أقوم اليوم بزيارة مركز جماعي للنازحين
ممول جزئيًا من قبل الوكالة الأمريكية للتنمية الدولية.
الذي يضمن للنازحين الحصول على
دفء المأوى الغذائي في الشتاء القادم
، وهناك كنت فخورًا بالإعلان عن
25 مليون دولار إضافية من الولايات المتحدة
لدعم الأشخاص المستضعفين في أوكرانيا
خلال فصل الشتاء القاسي المقبل ،
وستتوسع هذه الأموال الجديدة في التخطيط لفصل الشتاء
وجهود الاستجابة و  توسيع
نطاق المساعدة إلى ما يقرب من
75000 من الأسر الأكثر تضرراً